vanessa carlton clearing the record
was that something that caught you by
surprise even
yeah kind it did because i ain't never
eating like i
i never thought we'd ever cross paths
one day
ever in life you know what i'm saying so
we just think of white chicks
yeah it's a crazy i talked to her on the
phone i'm like man you
you got some white chicks yeah she
laughing we just laughing and vibing and
[ __ ] like that
so it's just like it was really dope
though for her to even do that and the
way she came out and opened up you know
what i'm saying so
it all played it all played his role and
actually was a success
no for sure and you actually like had
some like uh conversations with her
yeah she's she's solid yeah she's solid
for sure
she's real solid she cool she be in her
own world like you know what i'm saying
so she
she thought yeah from without from for
whatever you feel me
yeah i think if anybody were to guess
like a relationship that would transpire
in music uh last on my guesses would be
young and ace and vanessa carlton
for sure having a friend supposed to be
doing a tour or something [ __ ] like uh
pilot i think nothing yell she told me
come on uh if you if you
open up on a vanessa carlson tour my my
whole world has exploded
i can't wait to see i already told her i
was gonna do it so but you know so crazy
because i really
i was telling my label and stuff i
really wanted to like
like do like her doing a piano
like a uh always called like a live like
performance thing
right now i'm saying i want to do hell
and compensate her part well all that
just rap like you know what i'm saying
dude
everybody going to do their own part
she's just doing the acapella on the
computer straight strip down piano i
believe it's going to be so
vile bro it was when it went too crazy
yo
that's crazy